before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
this video is sponsored by atlasvpn
I've given my latest ranking for the
doctors
there's somebody else I gotta cover
[Music]
yes it's been the end of an era at the
end of gypnol's era the end of
Whitaker's time as the doctor but
we also got possibly we'll see what
happens a closeout for Sasha dewan's
master and even if it isn't
I think it's time that I do a fresh
ranking of the Masters all the same
uh pardon the outfit I actually don't
have cosplay of any of the Masters
specifically this is kind of just a
generic villainy kind of thing roll with
it okay so before I start this there are
a couple of things to go over first is
this is only going to be covering
Masters who appeared in the main show
I'm not going to say big finish has no
input but I will not be looking at Big
finish exclusive Masters because there
are a couple of those so that's the
first thing to understand the other
thing we got to cover is I gotta talk
about this video sponsor as scary as the
master can be the internet can be even
scarier trust me I've been on here a
while everything from security concerns
ads malware Atlas VPN can help you
navigate all of that and right now Atlas
is running the best VPN deal on the
market the steel Black Friday deal will
get you Atlas VPN premium for just a
dollar seventy a month for three years
plus six months extra and a 30 day money
back guarantee and to get that deal all
you have to do is click the link below
Atlas VPN allows you to protect an
unlimited number of devices on a single
subscription it'll help you block
malicious links keep your Google
searches private and most importantly
for somebody like me allow you to unlock
your favorite content from all over the
world it's hard enough trying to keep on
top of what services carry what shows or
movies you love but there's nothing more
frustrating than realizing they carry it
just not where you are so click the link
down below
get.atlasvpn.com Geeks it'll get you
access to what you want and keep you
safe from whatever Rogue time Lords may
be out there and so now it's time for us
to take a look at those who have
embodied the mantle of Master
starting at the bottom working our way
up
number eight
Eric Roberts now I know he has done some
big finish stuff I have not heard it yet
I've even heard some good things about
it but until I hear that all I have to
go off of
is the 90s Doctor Who TV movie and
he really doesn't work in that and I
feel bad saying that I saw him speak at
Gallifrey 1 earlier this year and he
seemed to genuinely enjoy Doctor Who
related things I'm pretty sure he did
the best that he could but honestly I
think a lot of it was the writing it
didn't seem to know what it wanted from
the master it went back and forth from
having him be almost robotic and almost
terminator-esque what happened to the
gunshot wound I brought in to just going
full flamboyant Camp by the end of that
I always dress for the occasion there
was no real consistency to it and he
didn't come across as a proper threat in
that I do hope to listen to some of his
big finished stuff and see if that bums
him up the list at a later time but for
right now I had still the bottom spot
number seven
Anthony ainley
classic Who fans are gonna be mad at me
about this one so
here's the thing basically what it comes
down to is Anthony ainley is Camp and
that in and of itself is not a problem I
don't have an inherent problem with
camping sometimes candy Doctor Who can
really work for me
the issue that I tend to have with the
master being Camp though and honestly
Camp villains in general is that they're
not threatening
I have a greater concern
one that will Encompass the whole human
race
and Anthony ainley rarely is now granted
there are still some classic appearances
from him that I have yet to see but as
it currently stands he was the closest
to intimidating right when he first
started right when we went from keeper
of Truckin uh into logopolis into
castrovalva that was about the strongest
and the closest to scary he ever came
across but after that he just he comes
across as more of a pantomime villain he
could he practically twirled his
mustache and went and
it's not that it didn't work but it's
not to my taste because I find nothing
intimidating about that I also don't
think he had especially good chemistry
with a lot of the doctors that he ended
up performing with he wasn't awful
working off of them but I'll bring it up
at later points sometimes the chemistry
that the master has with the doctors
that they're performing with does a lot
to boost things and he didn't really
have that going for me
number six
John Sim so now that I've already ticked
off the classic Who fans now I can take
off the modern era fans because yeah
John Sim
here's the thing
even though I don't think he's actually
gone up in the ranking I didn't go back
and check my uh the last time I did this
because I don't I don't try and stay
consistent it's just a this this is uh
my feelings right now so I don't go back
and compare but
I do actually think better of him now
but I'm not sure he actually moved in
placement because this gets dragged down
by his first appearance
I really don't care for him in the three
episodes he appears in series three
originally his first debuted in Utopia
sound of drums last of the time Lords
there's a manic kind of energy there
that I can appreciate but he's just a
little bit too
cartoonish it's not quite to Anthony
English level of camp but just the
extent to which it's trying to make him
seem like a villain who's having fun but
it's taken to such an extreme that
there's just the giddiness isn't the
same as like a villain being really
excited at their evil plan he just he's
bouncing off the walls in a way that
just isn't engaging for me now I
actually think he got better with every
appearance he made that seems to be a
slightly controversial opinion but
basically when he showed up in the end
of time Parts one and two he worked much
better for me that similar energy was
there but this time it was tempered by
the fact that he was actively falling
apart he was kind of breaking down and
so it felt less like uh well let's just
make him wacky kind of thing and it felt
more determined and informed by what was
happening to him as a character and so I
like that better and then I liked him
even and more when he showed up again at
the end of series 10 for the doctor
falls that I think was his strongest
performance as he just had this sense of
smugness he just thinks he has
everything figured out and he embodies
that really well so even though he got
better with every appearance
it did still start out rough for me so
that's why he is where he is
number five
the crispy Master this is actually a
combination I think last time I did this
I ranked the two primary performers who
played this incarnation of the master
Peter Pratt and Jeffrey beavers
separately I'm gonna bring them together
here because they are effectively
playing the same Incarnation but the
ranking of this where where it is is
largely down to Jeffrey beavers who I
think does great work getting that sense
of desperation and bitterness because
the idea of this incarnation of the
master is he is on what is supposed to
be and what he believes to be his last
Incarnation that's why he's walking
around in this horrible burned up State
he has no regenerations left so he's
gonna hang on and clutch to whatever he
can even as he is this burnt out
decrepit falling apart creature he won't
let himself just die even though if he'd
had any regeneration he would have used
one right now and that sense of really
Clinging On just hanging out by the
fingernails is very much in the better
instances of this character and Jeffrey
beavers who have not only seen in some
of the performances like say keeper of
Truckin but I've heard in some of the
big finish like with master and he
brings a great sense of
just being too stubborn too bitterly
viciously stubborn to just die and uh
and it works pretty dang well
number four
Sasha Dewan this one's kind of funny to
me because in a lot of ways it seems at
least to my taste like a refinement of
John Sim because Dewan brings a fairly
similar manic energy to the proceedings
but he never gave me the sense of like
just bouncing off the walls it just felt
more like unbridled Joy at the misery he
was bringing on to people he like he he
had a plan and he was locking himself
down as best as he could whereas Sims
seemed to just be happy to let himself
go to a degree that didn't quite work
for me at least in his first appearance
here Dewan feels like he's he's trying
to keep on top of it but he's just he's
he's giddy at the chance to mess with
the doctor and there's also a lot of
smaller subtler things there's some
there's actually a couple the most
blatant being in the most recent episode
of Power of the doctor but there are
some clear moments of deep self-loathing
that really makes it feel like this
isn't just someone who is villains for a
villainous sake there is thought to go
into why is he like this right now and
the little bits that we get hints of
which maybe will get explored eventually
in big Fitness or if he shows up again
in the show we don't really know exactly
what will happen there yet but I do hope
that that can get explored more because
even though we don't know for certain
that Dewan comes after Missy
that will go away of explaining it if
this is an Incarnation that kind of
can't stop himself whatever growth Missy
had had to be able to temper and
redirect her her machinations
Dewan doesn't have and so he falls back
into those patterns but that little bit
of self-loathing
actually makes him make sense possibly
as a successor to Missy in that way so
he brings that high energy that Sim had
but it just feels better focused and it
feels a little bit tempered and just the
right way that I needed and that Sim
would do later but the one did pretty
much off the bat
number three
the war master
oh big finish
is a major factor here so like I've
always liked the war master I have
always liked Derek Jacoby like that
first turn to camera in Utopia he is so
intimidating and he is immediately the
master kind of what's awesome though if
you're listening to the big finish or
Master stuff is just getting a sense of
How Deeply
manipulative he is
because when we see him in Utopia he is
passing as Professor Yan who's this
wonderful you know affable nice sweet
guy and that's not Who the Master is
but much like how John Smith was an
aspect of the doctor and those
components were still in there even
after David Tennant gained control of
his body again in that two-parter back
in series three where is he
John Smith is it in some way Professor
Yana is a component of the war master
and he can call on that and he can pass
as somebody who cares he can trick
people into thinking he has a heart he
can trick people into thinking he
doesn't mean them harm but he does he
always does but he is so good at
manipulating his way into getting
exactly what it is he wants and what he
wants is never ever anything good he is
tense scary intimidating and like again
most of this
it's like a fraction of an episode in
series three and then it's audio but
dang does it ever work
before I do the top two I should stress
these top three are really neck and neck
there is a decent chance that when I do
this next that especially if I've
listened to more big finish stuff damn
Jacoby might be at the top like you need
to realize how close these top three are
so that having been said
number two
Roger Delgado
the original master and he did suffer
unfortunately from overuse after first
being introduced and he did tragically
pass away far too early but I'll tell
you what the chemistry
the rapport
of him and John purtue it makes so many
episodes
it made me love the original sea Devils
which upon rewatch that I did not too
long ago isn't as good as I remembered
it but the stuff between the two of them
is excellent and he really has the
presence that sells you on the idea that
he can hypnotize somebody just by
looking at them when Roger Delgado did
it the way he would just look
at someone that commanding presence
yeah I could buy he could hypnotize
people just by looking at them he
absolutely sold that and he was Suave
yet also laid back whenever he thought
he was winning but then he could get
angry and snarling almost when he
realized he wasn't winning he was the
perfect match
for the doctor the third doctor in
specific and there's a reason that the
character has been brought back
continuously since he was made worth
bringing back because of this
performance
he was my number one last time
I have shifted around a bit which means
that when it comes to
number one
it's Missy
Michelle Gomez brings
so much to this part she brings that
chaotic energy and she's fun
I love how fun she is but also in her
best moments and this holds true for her
appearances in big finish as well she is
never far away from reminding you she
may be fun she may be quippy she may be
funny
She's Dangerous no I've not turned good
and she is never more than a few minutes
away from reminding you just how
dangerous she is
[Music]
whereas the war Master puts people at
ease by showing a false face
Missy Ken law the audience if not and
sometimes even the other characters
into a false sense of security
by her presence
she's fun she seems to be enjoying
herself
and it becomes easy to forget that her
enjoying herself
probably means somebody's gonna die soon
she has phenomenal chemistry with Peter
Capaldi the two of them it like it it is
no easy thing to sell the master any
incarnation
wanting to get better not just being
better but wanting to she sells that she
sells that because of the chemistry that
she has with Capaldi previous Masters
have sold that the history was there
that there was a past of friendship
Roger Delgado absolutely sold that sense
Missy sells the idea that there's still
something there maybe even she wants it
again enough
to try
but even in trying to be quote unquote
good she's still gonna be Missy and
she's still gonna be dangerous she's
still gonna be chaotic and she's still
gonna be
my favorite master
at least this time this ranking has
changed before it may change again like
I said those top three especially are
really close
really really close
like right up until the last minute I
did Shuffle these around and
you asked me another day even I might do
it a different order but this is what
I'm doing right now
that is the ranking my thanks again to
Atlas VPN link down in the description
for that deal that I talked about
earlier but I also want to hear your
thoughts on this
how would you rank the Masters what are
your thoughts on the big finish
exclusive Masters if you're familiar
with those what are some stories from
either big finish or classic Who because
I still haven't seen all of classic that
you think I could see that would help me
maybe better appreciate some of the
Masters who are lower ranked on here
whatever your thoughts are on any of
this drop something down in the comments
and let's talk about it
patreon is how I pay the bills in
addition to the generous sponsors that I
very occasionally am able to set
something up with but even if you can't
support me that way like share subscribe
they help me out as well there's links
down in the description uh further down
in the description that can also show
you the other things that I do other
platforms you can see me on other ways
you can support me but
don't worry too much about that
what I really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
end credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin fulla Tarak the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi Leota Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shea lugurley Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
the only kind deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]